Film Courage: How do you push your art to the next
level? Photographer/filmmaker/founder of MAKE ART NOW Youtube channel, Josh Yeo: Yeah, I think every time you do
something you have to attempt something
new.
And I try to do that in
every single video. if I don't feel like
I'm on the brink of failure every time
I'm doing something wrong.
I get bored if I do something
repetitive so I tried it like I just
find a new way to do it I think that's
probably why it takes so long for me to
get out videos it's because there's not
really a cookie cutter thing for me it's
all about refining that art and pushing
it even further I think you had said and
this was maybe when you were at the Sony Youtube
Camp? Yeah I think this was you who said
that if you're not excited by what
you're making that your audience won't
either
and and that don't try to like pander to
the audience maybe it sounds like
something okay was that on my video or
someone else's no there we watched
several and by the way it looked really
cool to go to that oh my god it was so
much fun
yeah Sony put on such a hit show for
everybody I mean it was so great
especially just being around all the
other content creators and feeling that
camaraderie of like hey we're all in the
mix like this so that was probably one
of the healthiest things that a content
creator can do for their psyche is being
around other content creators who are
going through the same stuff and you
really learn that you we're all on the
same side there's no competition of like
who's doing better than who it's like
we're on the same team that was super
helpful but going back to your question
yeah I I do genuinely feel that if I'm
not invested if I'm not excited by what
I'm making how am I supposed to get
someone else excited about it I've
literally stopped episodes in the middle
of the episode and I'm like I don't want
to do this and I stop I'm like I'm gonna
stop throwing good money after bed
because I'm no longer excited about this
it's me selling a product or it's me
doing something for views like I was
just working on an iPhone 11
I had strapped it to a drone and I was
gonna fly it and show the world what
iPhone Elevens new processor does for
video in the dynamic range and this is
what a glimpse of next year's drones
will look like and about halfway through
I was like I don't even like it, why
would I like try to prop up iPhone 11
sales at all like what because the video
is gonna do well I'm like I'm out I'm
out I saw I stopped a video will never
see the light of day well I mean from an
outsider's perspective seeing that Sony
camp it was great to kind of like live
vicariously there and and what's
interesting is maybe this is just been
my experience but with acting I think
there's way more competition I've seen
in the YouTube space the people seem to
be pretty satisfied with where they're
at in terms of there's not as maybe it's
all below the surface but when you meet
people it's not that weird actor your
actor sort of competition yeah that was
one thing that I was used to having that
kind of edge on your shoulder with the
actor thing you know like because in the
acting world if one person's one
person's success meant everyone else's
failure like they they were getting cast
repeatedly so that role is not available
for you but in the YouTube space that
has nothing to do with it at all if
somebody's video does well it actually
may make your channel more successful
because it'll pave the way for you to
say oh that's working that's something I
can do or you know maybe maybe I'll try
that and it so it's different it's it's
a totally different dynamic for sure
when I first came into the YouTube space
it felt I felt more camaraderie
especially when I did a good video I was
expecting people to be upset or jealous
but it was the opposite they reached out
to me they were genuinely happy for my
success they were like wow you really
you knocked it out of the park or Wow
another banger or you know whatever it
was and they would have some questions
or whatever but genuinely happy for my
success and that was very refreshing
what do you think that is I've seen the
same you know on a smaller scale
I've noticed that there doesn't seem to
be that that like edge I just I think
its inherent of putting up bodies of
work and putting yourself out there and
saying and putting your name on it and
then being you know sending it up to the
gods and whether it's gonna be rejected
whether you're gonna be torn apart I
think it takes a certain humility to do
that and so I feel like you know we're
all in this together is the kind of the
mentality of like wow you put up a body
of work like you did it Wow you know
good for you and if it's a success then
it's like awesome we know how hard it is
we know how difficult it is to to have a
video go viral like man you deserve it
it's not the same as like the the actor
thing because there's no yeah that
competition is just not really there one
person's success does not mean everyone
else's failure or lack of success
it just means their success when you
were at the Sony camp did you did you
feel validated like wow this is I'm here
because of my work I'm here because I'm
really like painstakingly looking at
what I'm doing and making sure that if
it's my it was an interesting dynamic
because that it was the first time that
I had been anywhere where I knew all the
people there but I hadn't met them right
so I knew everyone's name and knew where
they were from I knew what their shtick
was I knew what the cameras they use I
knew personal things about them and I
and then being like face to face I'm
like oh oh I'm Josh by the way that was
like it was a weird dynamic but it
taught me that you know as the as the
creator it's kind of a one-way
relationship that you're crafting with
the audience so like they're getting to
know you there the more they see you on
screen the more they get to know you the
more they fall in love with you the more
they whatever it is right but yet you
don't know anything about them and so
it's it's
it's definitely something to be mindful
of and so I was very aware of that at
the Sony event where I was like wow I
feel like I know all these people but
but if they don't watch my channel they
don't they have no idea who I am you
know so it was weird
you